welcome to new rapid game this is what's
the sky uke catch okay so let's get
going it's new to the pool yeah we we
are still in the early stages of that
new pool system but I got a good game um
out of that yesterday with the Alvin's
by the way if you watch this
continuously you will notice that I have
gained like two points or something in
the meantime this is because I won a
game in that pool but only my opponent
disconnected after like two minutes some
some connection hey Carper guess so i
get the semi slav hmm yeah it's a little
bit of a soft spot in my repertoire come
on let's let's keep it very simple and
capture and hope is not sitting down you
wit with a whole library of books f
looking up to player I Quincy to was a
little bit more challenging but anyway
maybe we are heading for the mainline
exchange in any case may be
yeah it seems to transpose into some
mainline not age five is the modern
modern or fashionable modern is wrong
it's not very modern but it's it's the
fashionable idea and the idea that has
made this line a little bit more
attractive for black and recent
top-level chest okay a 6 a-6 is not
quite clear what it is doing yeah maybe
he wants to prepare some 10 c5 something
no b5 now it has a quite yet sir a very
committal move which which leaves the
sea pawn quite weak
okay so it's an interesting moment yeah
I won't know that could be a case we're
taking on f6 does make some sense so
this is speeding up speeding up
proceedings yeah I guess so and now yeah
how to how to fight against or on the
queenside not against the Queen side on
the queenside it's probably the better
term how yeah a couple of ideas i can
try to reroute a night to see 5 this
night from c3 to be 3 for example would
be quite nice i can also put a look on
the C file another idea is to play
Knight to e5 which is not bad just that
I'm not quite sure if it is some best in
this position I can also all play a form
that's also quite an interesting
interesting option okay i think i'm
going to try to reroute the night to be
three it also gains a bit of time by
attacking the pawn so he has to make a
knot castle let's say he has to play a
slow we should be seven or a queen move
yeah not quite clear what is going to do
one of those two queen bee 6 may will be
six interesting Roxy one would be would
be an obvious move but well then it's
not quite clear emanate from each was
going okay yeah he's preparing c5 quite
yet directly
night see one I one they're after not
see one you might really have survival
right okay I mean I'm a little bit
better after that but I wonder if it's
the best way best way to do things the
rook seemed one Bishop e7
Knight d2 to be three is also possible
but he's always ready for a move like
Nigeria good I have an idea if I go look
to see one let's do that and he goes
Bishop d7 I have 95 I have options to
sometimes take that bishop I know that
looks very weird to take that bishop but
it's a defender so and here i am here my
ideas night was noisy three combining
ideas okay i know i originally wanted to
go to see one and so on but now it's
important he's got age 6 plate so my
threat of night f5 is pretty
inconvenient as he probably cannot go g6
due to the sacrifice yeah i can i can
sacrifice on g6 yeah probably
immediately or after 95 95 might be even
better that the better I don't know
yeah but that's a good position now
night f5 is this very very inconvenient
now g6 takes home takes Queen g6 check
has to go to d8 I guess and 95 not f5
now that's not going to that's not going
to be survived by black don't don't see
that so it probably has to allow night
f5 that's not good that's not good fam
yeah Castle so I mean not a happy move
but what else
whoa so he intends to cover wants to go
to f8 huh huh
ok
yeah I know it looks very tempting but
Queen have AIDS how to proceed out of
that is ideas to kick me out again with
g6 okay I can just yeah I can actually
just do that just 95 is good
okay check black resigns okay that was
that was the queen okay yeah we still
get some sumbitch man mismatches in the
in the early days of the pool let's
still have a recap I played that simpler
continuation here in the semi Slav just
trading this is some not very
threatening for black but I wanted a
simple position when Bishop e7 which is
fine of course on the the main antidote
against my line is this here for black
developing the bishop could claim okay
this all very normally and now you end
with this awkward a 6b five idea who
should be three and b5 yeah the problem
is it doesn't help black in some way and
it just creates weaknesses the pawn
enter square here on c5 when the castles
even age 6 yeah now I think taking is
right not wasting any time took with
annoyed now here I think it is a couple
of options but let us make quite some
sense I guess I didn't really I didn't
really see at that moment that I have
this idea the nigerian aight f5 IDM but
ok it was probably a keys of having the
right term feel for the pollution
because i think that's pretty strong
considering that he has played age 6
that's very relevant if he would have
the porn age 7 you can always go g6 and
then cover cover their five ya hear
probably Bishop d7 is a bit here this
thing is a bit a bit tougher I mean
white is substantially better but it's
it still continues yeah he also suffers
from that awkward queen position
here and now not g3 I don't believe I
don't really see how is how I should go
I should play now after g6 it's really
interesting i mean i can take or i can
do 95 both both moves look pretty good
now like this intending bishop g6 here
you might have 97 to hold on or hang on
nobody but the question is what about
this if i take it i think i probably
would have done that if he goes here
then night and five is going to win
immediately so he has to go if he goes
here is running into a check i mean
channeled don't really believe that so i
guess here and then night f5 and 95 that
that's what I saw it looks very tempting
night f7 is a is a threat and tsking huh
yeah maybe maybe you should have tried
g6 simply too kind of challenge me I
like do you really want to take okay the
thing is that I don't have to i can play
all kinds of um yeah strategic moves
even though mention 95 is not bad if he
goes 97 i can trade and just continue to
play here one thing is he still haven't
probably cannot castle you to Bishop to
g6 and here I'm trying to to reroute the
night like let's say here he does
whatever castles and I'm going back for
ninety three nights if I that it's just
very comfortable for white with those
problems here on the queenside yeah
after that it's probably probably not
playable okay that blend us the queen
but if he goes back um I think I was not
totally sure but I thought you four
would be good yeah and the engine
is he for is pretty good the ideas just
to open up the center very quickly if
you go with g6 I can even take it and
that i did not see but it's fairly it's
fair and surprising that the Amish I
like this yeah because this is check
going to end in a mate probably yeah
it's fairly unsurprising that white has
got a strong attack okay thanks for
watching